over the last 10 years we have heard the
term blockchain quite often
especially when we have been following
banking investing or
cryptocurrency most of us tend to
complicate this term with complex
definitions and explanations
well let's take a minute to understand
what blockchain means in a very simple
manner
blockchain at the most basic level is a
chain of blocks
where the block refers to digital
information and
chain refers to public database each
block in the chain
consists of several transactions and
every time there is a new transaction on
the blockchain
a record of that transaction will be
added
so blockchain can be defined as a system
of recording information that
makes it difficult or almost impossible
to hack
change or cheat the system let's
understand
two different terms here distributed
ledger technology
and cryptocurrency distributed ledger
technology or
dlt is a decentralized database managed
by
multiple participants in the blockchain
so
blockchain is a type of dlt where the
transactions are recorded with a hash
an immutable cryptographic signature
talking about cryptocurrency it is a
virtual or
digital currency that is secured by
cryptography
which makes it nearly impossible to
counterfeit many cryptocurrencies are
decentralized networks based on
blockchain technology well now that you
have an idea
of what blockchain means and how it
works let's now talk about the
blockchain island
so how about we play a small guessing
game
i shall give you three different clues
to name this country
and see if you can guess it right this
european country is an
archipelago in the central mediterranean
and is known for its historic sites
related to the succession of the rulers
like romans
moons etc also this country has
numerous fortresses and megalithic
temples and the last clue
which is more than of a lesser-known
fact about this country
this is the famous filming location for
biggest budget productions
could you guess which country are we
talking about well
the answer is malta the first country in
the world
with clearly established regulatory
frameworks for dlts
malta has positioned itself as a go-to
place for various innovative fintech
companies
and blockchain entrepreneurs this island
has attracted plenty of international
talents
working in the sectors such as igaming
and financial services
which is utilized for growing blockchain
industry it has also attracted the two
largest crypto exchanges venus and ok x
it is fast establishing a reputation as
a hub for digital innovation and
preparing its finance sector
for a data-driven and ai-powered future
malta's vision is to create a thriving
blockchain economy
by providing regulatory certainty and
consumer protection to a market
environment
that is unregulated in many countries
blockchain is estimated to generate an
annual business value
of more than 3 trillion dollars by 2030.
malta has joined hands with switzerland
and singapore
to form regulations on tokens to speed
up the growth of blockchain development
an island between europe and africa
malta is one of the smallest countries
globally with a population less than
half a million
today there are hundreds of crypto
businesses on this island
while many significant economies were
reluctant to regulate blockchain and
cryptocurrencies
malta adopted a remarkably progressive
stance towards blockchain technologies
and cryptocurrencies
the country introduced a comprehensive
set of rules and regulations
to safeguard the investors while
supporting the growth of stakeholders
and industry the malta digital
innovation authority
the malta financial services authority
and the malta gaming authority are the
three different authorities
involved in regulating and overseeing
the sector
malta believes blockchain can help
transform the education systems
and the country's transportation
blockchain promises to reduce
transaction costs and
improve security although other
countries are focusing on
cryptocurrencies malta's attention is
mainly on the blockchain technology
and its more comprehensive application
the maltese minister for transportation
said that the blockchain technology is a
vital part for their overall national
strategy
to transform various sectors across the
government
to improve the island's public
transportation network
the government announced a partnership
with the british blockchain platform
omnitude all in all the european country
with a thriving and stable economy that
has taken a stance
to regulate the blockchain sector is
malta
why malta wants to become the blockchain
island
here are the five reasons why malta
wants to become the blockchain island
to establish malta as a crypto economy
giant
it's great for the economy to attract
the world's largest cryptocurrencies
to offer blockchain businesses to a
stable business environment
that attracts investors and finally
to benefit the blockchain technology
innovation
malta has recognized cryptocurrency is
the future of money
and has made great strides in
establishing itself
as the hub for this emerging sector
joseph
bogg the head of the blockchain advisory
at wh partners legal firm
said that malta has accepted the fact
that blockchain technology
and cryptocurrencies are inevitably
going to become
more popular borg is very optimistic in
this aspect
but also says that it's too early to
tell whether
this pioneering venture will be
successful
malta's prime minister joseph musket was
famous for his favorable blockchain
stance and helped name the country as
blockchain island however his
resignation in 2019
has left the island's future stance on
blockchain uncertain
whether malta will continue to hold the
name of blockchain island in the future
remain somewhat unsure at the moment
all we can say right now is to wait and
see where the blockchain technology
evolves into